around five point five thousand years
ago the bowtie people in northern
Kazakhstan began riding and milking
horses this was the beginning of horse
domestication which allowed humans to
travel much faster connect to vast
territories and develop advanced warfare
since then horse domestication has
transformed civilization but how exactly
have the transformed the horse recently
researchers sequenced the genomes of
Inchon horses from four point one to two
point three thousand years old
thirteen samples come from the royal
burial sites of Skippy's nomads who
ruled much of Central Asia
during the Iron Age the barrel site is a
rare snapshot of a horse population
eleven samples all from the same
generation sacrifice the same day as a
part of a funeral ritual and almost
perfectly preserved in permafrost these
samples tell us a lot about Skippy ins
and their horses first the genomes show
that the horses in their herds had a
variety of prose colors Skippy endorses
carry diverse mutation is relating to
speed states and endurance some of them
had gene variants found in today's
fastest racing horses while others had
gene variants associated with stamina
researchers found 121 genes selected by
schedules including a large number
involved in the development of the legs
of horses it seems Skippy and breeders
selected for strong lay
examination of the bones from the burial
site and other skin Ian's remains
confirm this finding by comparing
ancient genomes with present-day genomes
researchers came away with new insights
on horse domestication and animal
domestication in general Skippy and
horses had a variety of y chromosomes
which means male lineages in the first
3,000 years of domestication were
diverse modern samples however show that
breeders seem to use less and less of a
variety of males up to the point that
today's horses all carry virtually the
same Y chromosome this tells us that the
horse population has collapsed within
the last twenty three hundred years
which resulted in a reduction of horse
genetic diversity at the whole genome
scale during the same time period
breeding practices must have led to the
introduction of harmful mutations
because modern horses show an abundance
of these mutations while 15 horses don't
looking at the changes in horse genomes
also gives support for a domestication
hypothesis involving neural crest cells
because these cells develop into many
different tissues and cell lineages
changes in them might explain why many
domestic animals share a group of traits
like floppy ears and various coat
problems
so studying the genomes of skip Ian's
horses is starting to bring these
ancient animals to life but it'll take
many many more samples and from all
along the timeline and across the globe
to tell the whole story of horse
domestication
[Music]
you
[Music]